Leigha and pedro pushed two tables
together the figure below shows the new
arrangement so we have table number one
and table number two the lia and pedro
have pushed together maybe they're
having a bunch of people over for a
fancy breakfast and so they've pushed
one two tables together to have a lot of
room for people to sit and we're asked
what is the perimeter of the new figure
perimeter is the distance around the
outside so all of this space around the
outside is the perimeter and we need to
figure that out so what we could do we
could say here we know there's three
meters around the outside here's another
meter so that's four meters around the
outside but then we get to here and uh
we don't have this one and we don't have
this side length or this length or this
link so we can't know the entire
distance around the outside until we
figure out what those missing side links
are so let's fill in some of those first
because these tables are rectangles
opposite sides are equal so if this side
down here is one meter then this side up
here has to be one meter
same here if this is three meters the
opposite side is also three meters and
we have one meter on the end of this a
table so the inside this length from
here to here is also one meter but
that's an interesting one this one meter
here because this part now right here
that's on the inside of the arrangement
that's not the outside so that is not
part of the perimeter so this one meter
will not be included in our perimeter
but it is still important to us and
here's why this length and this length
are part of the outside and we need to
know how long those are so what we can
say is if this entire length is three
meters then this entire length is three
meters but one of those meters was moved
to the inside so how many meters are
still left here on the outside
we had three meters over here we moved
one to the inside so we have two meters
left on the outside so this length and
this length are a total of two meters we
can't know for sure they look pretty
evenly divided we can't know for sure
that they're both one meter but we do
know for sure that it's a total of two
meters when we can bind them so again
this one meter is not on the outside
it's not part of our perimeter but it
did help us to find the other links okay
now everything is labeled so we can get
back to finding the perimeter the
distance around the outside will be all
of these lengths put together so here we
have one meter plus moving down the
outside three more meters plus one more
plus one here on that side we just
figure it out plus another three one on
the end
another long side of three and finally
one more meter going up the side so we
can add these links when we combine
these links they'll tell us the total
distance around the outside one plus
three is four plus one more is five plus
one more is 6 6 plus 3 is 9 9 plus 1 is
10 10 plus 3 is 13 and 13 plus one more
is 14 so the perimeter of the new figure
of this new table arrangement is 14
meters